meantime here at home several regular
unemployment insurance claimants have
been reaching out to eight news now
about a claim filing problem
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis they say
after a new claim option popped up they
feel stuck and they're worried about
getting future payments
joe mohler live again in dieter with
what we know so far about this
issue joe well brian a lot of people
were wondering if this was some sort of
glitch they went to file their weekly
claim and then they were asked to file
another whole separate claim
well many thought this would have to do
with those extensions that dieter
recently announced
it started off when i first got the
my double dip kind of notification
caitlyn millis says many claimants were
confused when their unemployment portal
had
two filing options this past week many
clicked it thinking it had to do with
recently announced extensions previous
with the extension
what the group has suggested to do was
to file your weekly claim and then file
for the extension that popped up
automatically
under your unemployment after filing the
second claim people were flagged for
filing twice
now many are scrambling trying to get in
contact with dieter to avoid missing a
payment
i'm not sure why that would pop up under
their thing
uh i feel like it was a glitch maybe
yeah i think it probably was a glitch
this is a popular topic on many
unemployment facebook pages
70 percent of the people got this on
regular unemployment
sierra neil is an administrator on a
popular facebook assistance group
she says if you don't have exhausted
benefits avoid clicking it
you are able to file your weekly
claim do not touch that link
it will cause that issue people must
contact dieter to get this fixed
millis says she luckily got through on
the phone early tuesday i called in
using the steps that they
suggested waited about an hour the
the representative was able to fix my
issue within five minutes
now that number that millis had success
with we went ahead and put it on the
graphic in the bottom of your screen
there we also did reach out to dieter
today to see if we can get some sort of
answer to find out if this was
actually a glitch we've yet to hear back
as soon as we do we'll be sure to update
this story
reporting live outside the dealer office
joe mullen 8 news now joe thank